like many garment workers across
Bangladesh rumor begum is trying to
survive by cutting costs food prices
kept going up she's a single mother who
has to support a teenage daughter and
her mother with her meager wages
the way the current situation is with
the high price of Essentials it's become
very hard for us to get by with the
wages we get it's like choosing between
salt or rice we want our wages to be
raised
labor leader Colton actor believes wages
should be raised to help them face these
challenges she says workers spend on an
average of 30 to 40 percent of their
salaries on rent and the rest is for
food and there's nothing left for health
care or savings
since the covet pandemic prices of
Essentials have gone up but wages have
not increased at all and for the last
one and a half years due to the Ukraine
and Russian war the cost of living went
up very high in contrast with the
workers purchasing ability
union leaders and organizations set a
minimum wage which is 95 dollars a month
should be increased to at least 226
dollars a month and say Global buyers
Brands and retailers must come together
to support the call the Bangladeshi
expert markers has largely been driven
by the ready-made garment industry which
is highly dependent on keeping wages low
in order to remain competitive in the
global market
industry leader Farooq Hassan is
receptive to the demand and also thinks
the minimum wage should be raised we are
really looking from the buyer that they
should pay the fair prices and the
ethical prices so that we can also pay
uh more increased wages to our employees
so this is also responsibility from the
buyers because we are taking care of
their quality producing their quality
Goods last month a prominent workers
union leader Was Bitten to death by some
unknown man it happened more than 10
years after another worker leader was
tortured and murdered by unknown as
silence rights groups Ms dismissals
intimidation violence and no arrests of
workers after protests are common in
Bangladesh and call on the government
for the protection and advancement of
government workers and With Children Al
Jazeera sabar Bangladesh